séance studieuse pour marianne et
justine les deux étudiantes de 21 ans
originaire de plaisir ne sont pas en
train de réviser leurs cours mais de
préparer le 4l trophy un raid étudiant
solidaire entre la france et le maroc au
départ de biarritz au programme des 6000
km pistes désertiques du nez orientation
à la boussole c'est une expérience je
pense que on voit en apprendre beaucoup
de cette aventure notamment au lieu au
niveau humain par exemple il ya des gens
qui sont en galère ' on se voit on peut
s'arrêter et demander qu'est ce qui se
passe pour aider quoi c'est une belle
façon de découvrir le maroc et je pense
ça a été une aventure inoubliable
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas trop guerrière
sur la route pour ne pas avoir trop de
problèmes sur les chemins en sable et
les deux plaisirs oise ont testé leurs
voitures sur les routes du département
depuis son acquisition l'été dernier les
sportives ont également reçu des cours
de mécanique de la part d'un garagiste
local tous les genres on va devoir
checker le frère parce que avec le sable
il sera en sable et du coup il va
falloir ouvrir cette petite boîte là et
du coup à l'intérieur il ya le frère on
a une machine du coup qui va souffler
pour retirer tout stable moi je me sens
pas de calais en mécanique mais bon on
connaît les petites bases et franchement
on a un mécano super au top qui est
super passionnés du coup par les
vieilles voitures donc je suis sûr que
la voiture allait elle est en état pour
partir aujourd'hui ces deux têtes
brûlées sont prêtes à faire chauffer la
gomme leur objectif sur cette course
terminée dans les 300 premiers du
classement
pour cela marianne et justin ont une
stratégie alterné leur rôle dans les
dunes c'est moi du coup le pilote et
marianne mako pilote qui va me guider
tout le monde vous rendrez on va autant
conduire l'une et l'autre mais
comme c'était moi qui ai composé 4l
trophy je me suis mis en tant que pilote
mais officiellement à toutes les deux
pilotes prochaine arrêts pour les deux
plaisirs oise le 20 février prochain
devront se rendre au village départ à
biarritz avec leur 4l rose pour une
dernière vérification technique avant le
grand départ à leur tour est lui prévu
le 3 mars avec des souvenirs plein la
tête